le film mignonne moi je pense que plein
de petites filles qui rêvent qui se
déhanchent devant devant kim kardashian
devant rihanna
elles peuvent pas comprendre elles sont
trop petit c'est vraiment pas les
mépriser que dire ça là là on parle plus
de femmes brigitte bardot c'était une
femme on parle d'enfants elles elles ne
comprennent pas que les regards qu'elle
suscite d'ailleurs c'est intéressant
parce que plein de deux d'enfants qui
ont été abusés pourquoi aussi elle ne se
sont pas plainte tout de suite qu'elles
ont attendu et après on le leur reproche
c'est que elle ne savait pas mettre un
nom sur ce qui était fait sur le pape
sur leur corps elles savaient pas que
c'était un regard sexuelle qu'elle
suscitait donc elle pouvait pas s'en
plaindre
et ça c'est terrible ce que j'ai ce
qu'il faut quand même tout temps tout en
étant extrêmement sévère avec avec tout
ce qui est tout ce qui est pédophile et
pédocriminels et de tout ce flou
artistique qui est effectivement hérité
de la société près de patriarcale il
faut par ailleurs prendre en compte que
quand on est un enfant on n'est pas une
femme et on n'a pas le même regard sur
son corps on n'a pas le même rapport au
corps et et après oui tout à fait
vouloir plaire le truc c'est qu'en plus
vouloir plaire c'est ses sens et naturel
mais après ce objets tease et oui je
suis désolé avant d'objets tease et il
faut se respecter il faut être
construite et quand on est fragile quand
quand on est dans une famille où on vous
respecte pas beaucoup pour plein de
raisons
quand on se sent pas bien c'est plus
dangereux dans tous les sens du terme de
ces objets tease et surtout à l'extrême
[Musique]